dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly show an IFA here in
1997 the news took the world by storm
Gary Kasparov
world champion and Grandmaster chess
player was defeated by an artificial
intelligence program by the name deep
blue in 2011 IBM Watson won first place
in the famous American quiz show
Jeopardy in 2014 google deepmind created
an algorithm that mastered a number of
Atari games by working on a raw pixel
input this algorithm learned in a
similar way as a human would this time
around google deepmind embarked on a
journey to write an algorithm that plays
go go is an ancient chinese board game
where the opposing players try to
capture each other's stones on the board
behind the veil of this deceptively
simple rule set lies an enormous layer
of depth and complexity as scientists
like to say the search space of this
problem is significantly larger than
that of chess so large that one often
has to rely on human intuition to find a
suitable next move therefore it is not
surprising that go on a high-level is or
may be was widely believed to be
intractable for machines this chart
shows the skill level of previous
artificial intelligence programs the
green bar shows the skill level of a
professional player used as a reference
the red bars mean that these older
techniques required a significant
starting advantage to be able to contend
with human opponents as you can see deep
Minds new program skill level is well
beyond most professional players an
elite pro player and European champion
fan who II was challenged to play
alphago google deepmind's newest
invention and get defeated in all five
matches they played together during
these games each turn it took
approximately two seconds for the
algorithm to come up with the next move
an interesting detail is that these
strange black bars show confidence
intervals which means that the smaller
they are the more confident one can be
in the validity of the measurements as
one can see these confidence interval
are much shorter for the artificial
intelligence programs than the human
player likely because one can fire up a
machine and let it play a million games
and get a great estimation of its skill
level while the human player can only
play a very limited number of matches
there is still a lot left to be excited
for in March the algorithm will play a
world champion the rate of improvement
in artificial intelligence research is
accelerating at a staggering pace the
only question that remains is not if
something is possible but when it will
become possible I wake up every day
excited to read the newest breakthroughs
in the field and of course trying to add
some leaves to the tree of knowledge
with my own projects I feel privileged
to be alive in such an amazing time as
always there is lots of references in
the description box make sure to check
them out thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time